quite a journey because because you you
grew up as an adoptive child yeah
Australia and there was but the English
have a problem with sex however it
manifests itself and in post-war years
to me the post-war years they didn't
know what to do with all the bastards
you know and if you had a bastard if you
had a child out of wedlock in those days
the girl in the in the case was treated
like a mental case or medical case and
put into a hospital or some kind of
asylum and that's what happened to my
mother she had me governor's and my
father is and she was treated some kind
of social leper and she was stuck in
this Asylum where she she went mad
really and died of TB when she was 28
but she wasn't alone in that many many
women who had children out of wedlock
were treated such in such a way and you
never met her never met her no it's
caused a break good day of course did
you did you grow up with some with
awareness of belonging to some class or
like I didn't belong to any type of
underclass really I suppose a very
working-class we lived in a place called
Cornwall which is right at the very end
of of England and very poor mining
districts clay mining and tin mining all
the rest of those things and we were
very very very poor my father was not
very successful businessman he yeah well
he was a carpenter actually and he built
caravans but it always cost him more to
build the caravans than he got when he
sold it so the kind of imbalance there
you know what I mean he was also a bit
silly as far as politics were concerned
he thought that if Churchill and Hitler
got together they could solve all the
problems of the world so it wasn't a
very fortunately if by any manner of
means and it was we were the lowest of
the lowest first class was concerned and
I spent my time climbing up the social
net and I mean here you are the next we
come back
how much is I'm in your language it's
it's in my ears anyway it's it's perfect
you know upper class British yeah it's
RP means uh penis but here's thing
that's changed you see as an actor I do
a lot of voiceovers for I would use two
for adverse and documentaries of
wildlife stuff from the British film
from the Bristol Natural History that's
right yeah BBC and in those days of
course it's the point about class if you
had an accent like mine you were fine
you talk like that that's fine
absolutely fine but nowadays this kind
of X and I've got now isn't wanted
you've got to talk like that you know
you have some kind of regional dialect
in order to get by and this kind of
language is pase pase belongs to a
previous generation so but could you
could you hear from from any English
person talk talking that what kind of
class he would be I mean /i his easing
lift yeah my accents long gone but when
I was little I had a very thick northern
accent northern yeah Midlands yeah how
would that sound I can't do it that you
don't like that yeah there's no other
access yeah yeah and and in my family
that's from there you know and I see
them on on occasion and they still have
that accent it's really strong but it's
very easily identifiable Sam Johnson the
Ben Johnson lovely the playwright's
said speak to me and tell me who you are
and he meant by the sound of your voice
by the way you spoke by your choice of
words and so on you could find out you
know who the man was where he came from
what class he came from so it's very
different from Cornwall and I had what
is thought of as a peasant accent talk
like that you see all the time and that
people think you're stupid when you talk
like that you have you have a lot of
fans also in Scandinavia I do I do
most of them are very lovely people and
and thank you if you're watching lovely
but I also have a few
mad ones I'm sure you do
there's one particular one whose name I
can't divulge she's from Norway and she
sends me big letters packages full of
the diet sheets because she thinks I'm
too fat and she sends me presents which
are quite expensive you know watches and
things like that
and she's also a karate expert and she
wrote the other day telling me what
she'd like to do with me and made my
eyes water I'm really thinking about it
you know so I haven't written back and
that's your wife get to open these
letters she does yes religiously yes yes
yes and so you probably won't see them
all
the most acclaimed most in life they
like gel metals thank you so much for
coming